i do want to break down the finale
with you guys so let's start with jack's
bait
is he okay well we don't know
no no he's on the floor bleeding we
don't know if he's okay
well i know because i've read everything
that you know comes after
i'm not saying he is i'm just saying i
know but so we should have hope for jam
never lose hope but i mean look monroe
is an amazing nurse practitioner
so he's in good hands you know he's off
to a good start there
if you want to be shot you're pretty
fortuitous
for your love interest to be a nurse so
you know he's off to a good start
but anything can happen on virgin river
that's true there's a lot of deaths
surrounding mel monroe so who knows
maybe it's like
i know it's just the cursing dramatic
when she
runs in to find her new love on the
floor bleeding to death
it's like they just got to this great
place
solidifying their love and then boom
he's down
alex actually ad-libbed the line in that
moment she just
threw her hands up in the air and she
went another one what is it with my
dying
loves who do we think did this to jack
well that's the big mystery isn't it
yeah i think the show kind of sets it up
so that you you think maybe it was jimmy
maybe some people no no definitely
no it's definitely charmaine i mean you
know
just do that do the math i'm convinced
no way yeah
i think you think it's brady yeah
i'm not gonna confirm or deny the
writers certainly are you leading you to
believe that it's that
group of people it's the calvin group of
people
right but maybe they'll twist and if
there's a season through maybe there
will be a twist in that
we don't know i do feel like jack and
mel's relationship has been tested
a lot but now they are seemingly all in
so how will this injury sort of affect
their relationship
moving forward should you guys get a
season
three well i guess that depends on if
he's alive or dead
doesn't it they're not going to kill him
i know this is a nice feel that's true
that would be really weird because then
you'd have to watch mel go through
basically what she did in season one all
over again first or three
that would be so tragic that would be so
tragic
especially for me because i don't want
to have to relive that stuff anymore
um no yeah i mean i think they're
i think they're all in at the end of
season two
do we think if you guys get a season
three
there would be an engagement in season
three
is mel even ready for that i don't know
if mel's ready for that
because i mean well here's the thing the
seasons take
place in such a short period of time
right right
each season is only like around a month
month and a half or so so really by
season three you would end up being
only a couple months in to their
relationship so
but they're they're going full speed
ahead they've already said i love you in
a short period of time
is it so i love you let's get married
kind of thing
maybe i don't know but jack's not you
know he's not really the marrying type
is he i mean yeah he's managed to avoid
that
uh set of circumstances and you know
he's kept charmaine at arm's length for
two years
so this is done his love to mel
he probably you know he's still gonna
work through his own
issues you know it's clearly the man's
got some commitment
phobia going on here so it'll be
interesting to see
how he tackles that a commitment phobe
until he met mel is what i would like
to think possibly i thought but
apparently i was wrong
let's talk about charmaine and the twins
for a second
do we think she's gonna move away with
the twins
i hope so i think that would be horrible
to deprive jack of the chance to be a
father i think
although he doesn't want to be with her
i think he's very much committed to
even though it freaks him out so i think
her
desire to move away would be something
that he would fight for
when those babies are born i mean what
types of hurdles do you guys
foresee for jack and mel
so many mel is going to see charmaine's
face every time she picks one of those
little babies out of the crib
oh you know that's that's not that's a
lot to ask of a woman i know
ovaries are going to be going into
overdrive
baby of my own
is jack gonna tell mel that charmaine
kissed him
should she she hates she
should shouldn't he hm that's a really
good question that's like one for the
ages i mean
i'd like to hear the audience's opinion
on that because
should we tell things to people knowing
that all it would really serve is to
hurt them
or do they deserve the full truth even
though it'll hurt them
just so they know that they haven't been
lied to by
permission i feel like mel would want to
know
but alex what do you think oh i i
definitely think that mel would want to
know that information
yeah but would it clean here i would
also want to know that
if if my significant other was kissed by
someone
same you know
[Laughter]
the show this season did hint at
jack's potential drinking problem
i'm curious if you think there's
actually a problem
that needs to be addressed there i mean
clearly there's a problem
i mean i think we set that up in season
one that
jack's way of dealing with his
demons particularly the ptsd stuff was
to kind of drown them
in alcohol but you know like all demons
with alcohol they they learn to swim and
so i think
inevitably he's going to be forced to
deal with the fact that
he's not really dealing with it and the
alcohol use
and but really why is he drinking in the
first place i think that's
leaves a lot of room for character
development and
you know although the i think the love
story will be the driving force
this his personal stuff will have to be
addressed as well
you know if he wants to be a fit father
and a husband
it's only fair husband are they getting
married
i'm just saying if there was a big if a
big capital f
underlined with exclamation marks if he
wanted to be a good
father and a husband he would have to do
that in my opinion
or not maybe mel would be happy with a
drunken man
coming home i think nellie's down the
law
yeah i agree that's so i'm advocating
for his recovery but
it's up to mel whatever she chooses
she's pretty tough she doesn't
put up with a lot i don't think she'd
put up with it that's very true
but she's tough but she's so soft on the
inside and i think that's what makes her
so compelling
to men everywhere
oh that was cute another character who's
fake we should be a little bit worried
about i think is doc
he is going to tell hope something and
then they are inundated with this
surprise re-engagement party
what do we think or what are each of
your guys's theories
on what is going on with him well i
think we're led to believe that he has
some kind of
health issue you know something is
something's going on we're not just not
quite sure what it is
and so that's scary because he just got
back together with hope i mean they
lost all of that time you know
so i hope it's not something really
terrible
i know what it is it's so obvious you
know
another major cliffhanger is preacher
paige michelle's friend drops off
christopher
are we gonna see a lot more christopher
potentially
in a season three and will we see pedro
michelle ever return
i'm not going to talk about paige and
michelle because that's a nice
mystery but you definitely see a lot
more of christopher
okay which is delightful young chase
lights the screen up oh i can't give too
much away
what should we think about her ex's twin
brother
slash detective that shows up to town is
he
could he cause some issues
um maybe i'm honestly trying to remember
what happened put that in context we we
shot
that we shot season two a year ago so i
so it was it's hard to remember some
things are a little cloudy
okay that'd be one of them because that
that whole the whole storyline gets very
complicated
what are the three things that you guys
would love to see
happen in season three i think more
babies is always good
um you know
triplets would be good twins got twins
i think if mel had quadruplets i think
we'd really even better
ride yeah all right
setting the bar very high juggle them
you juggle children like that oh i
clearly know how to juggle it all